ça devient invivable on nous interdit
tout et on nous donne rien en échange
non je ne pense que je ne sais pas j'ai
pas quand il a lieu savez je suis un peu
dégoûté de tout et puis j'ai écrit à
matran jeudi que la seule solution c'est
qu'il fallait arrêter de faire c'est de
laisser fermer des entreprises regardent
hérimoncourt c'est un véritable scandale
1 voilà des gens qui vont faire 170 km
par jour le matin pour aller bosser à
vesoul c'est un scandale et on veut
lutter contre la pollution veut lutter
contre la consommation de pétrole
et puis on fait des conneries comme ça
on ferme des usines qui sont rentables
c'est absolument scandaleux il faudrait
déjà refaire des voitures comme on
faisait autrefois comme les allemands
ont fait la volkswagen on devrait faire
des voitures qui sont accessibles pour
tous les gens qui ont des petits revenus
ça serait une première mesure la
deuxième mesure sortir du pétrole et
pour sortir du pétrole incité des gens
n'ont pas à prendre des voitures
électriques qui sont foutus au bout de
cinquante sept ans et ça on le sait
cette voie mais nous savons rien du tout
et
c'est tout comme ça tout on pousse les
gens la consommation ont les allège la
publicité à tout ça les gens achètent
des trucs dont il n'a absolument pas
besoin et ils ne savent plus vivre
simplement je vois l'avenir très très
mauvais ça devient invivable
on nous interdit tout et on nous donne
rien en échange